foreign
I am passionate about changing the world
one website at a time as Dale said I was
in a bad car crash a long time ago it
left us all with life-changing injuries
and that's why accessibility and website
accessibility has become my passion
the accident also left me with a very
bad memory so please forgive me for keep
looking at my notes
okay does everybody know what a cookie
Banner is
those annoying banners that pop up on a
website asking for consent to put
cookies into your browser
uh it may say something like this
website uses cookies to give you the
best online experience
follow this link to confirm that you
consent to this
does everyone know what I'm talking
about
good right now I want you to imagine a
different kind of browser this one says
the following
this website is designed for white
people only
follow this link to confirm that you are
white
or
this website is for men only
follow this link to confirm that you are
a man
or
this website is for straight people only
follow this link to confirm that you are
straight
or even
this website is for people who have hair
follow this link to confirm you have
hair
okay these don't happen in the real
world but what I do need to tell you
about is another Banner that does exist
on over 97 of the world's websites
this website is for people who are not
disabled
follow this link to confirm that you are
not disabled
this may not be as apparent as the
cookie Banner believe me this Banner
exists
97.4 of 1 million website homepages
tested last year had detectable
accessibility failures
so how many disabled people are there in
the world in 2010 the World Health
Organization estimated that one billion
people on the planet live with some form
of disability
with over 110 million having highly
significant difficulties in functioning
we are talking about a lot of people
they also would like to use the web as
much as you or I do
they also want to become your customers
and spend money with you
if you make it possible for them to do
so
the title of this talk is a direct quote
from somebody I met last year she works
in health safety employee well-being and
has done for 20 years so she has a real
understanding of inclusivity
lovely caring person but she just could
not understand how blind people could
use the internet because they couldn't
see the screen
I explained to him what a screen reader
was and she got it a screen reader by
the way is a piece of software that
reads out the content of a website using
a computerized voice
if you're blind you can't use a mouse
because you can't see where to put it so
you will use your keyboard instead in
conjunction with the screen reader
not that easy to do but cookie banners
make life so much worse and in some
cases they actually prevent blind people
from accessing the website Beyond it
we are in the year 2022. the first set
of guidelines for websites to help
ensure that they met the needs of
disabled people were released quite
recently actually in 1999 a mere 23
years ago yep I'm not joking all the
information has been available to
everyone since then
it is also a legal requirement in most
countries but above everything else it
helps every business and every
organization become more inclusive
and yet 97 of websites contain
detectable accessibility failures last
year
think of a website as a building it
becomes even more obvious after all
websites the physical buildings they're
your window on the world aren't they
legislation for access to physical
buildings has always made allowances for
very old buildings where it's simply not
possible to make them fully accessible
for people with disabilities we all
understand that so actually I think it's
perfectly fair that you shouldn't expect
a website over 23 years old to cater for
disabled would be either I actually not
sure the last time I went to our website
it was over 23 years old
but what about five years old what about
three years old about last year this
year
typically websites get replaced every
three to five years as the new one is
built to cater for the latest trends is
it really okay that websites that are
recently built are still inaccessible
for disabled people
if not now
when
okay so what does accessible web design
actually mean
please take a look at these doors
they both go into the same building
both sets of doors have level access
the door on the left slides open
automatically as you approach it
the doors on the right have to be pulled
open
I would like to ask you all a question
and if you're able I would like you to
either raise your left hand
or your right hand in answer
imagine you're in a wheelchair and you
want to enter this building
which of the doors do you think you
would be most likely to use
the automatic doors on the left or the
heavy doors on the right could you
please raise your left or your right
hand accordingly
wow I think it's fair to say the
consensus is on the left interesting
okay now
um instead of being in a wheelchair
you're using a walking frame so you can
walk but you need to have both of your
hands on the frame which set of doors do
you think you would be likely to use now
could you raise your hands if you're
able to
I'm really surprised everyone's going
left okay
um right now you're pushing a child in a
push chair so you can walk quite
normally but you've got push chair and
both of your hands are on it which set
of those now left or right
I'm staggered
far okay final example let's assume that
you've actually gone in through the
doors on the right
you're coming out you want to come out
the building but you've actually got
boxes of files under both arms
which are the doors would you go then
yeah
I'm really staggered in pretty much
every example pretty much everybody
raised your left hand why was this after
all you're free to choose which door to
use in each time why would so many
people go for an automatic door
maybe because it's easier nobody's
forcing you to use it it's there as an
alternative to the other doors
accessible web design is exactly the
same offering people with different
needs alternative ways of using our
website to get the same information
most countries around the world have
anti-discrimination laws and websites
fall under these laws however for me
it's not about complying with the law it
is about becoming more inclusive more
welcoming to everyone regardless of
their ability or their disability
disabled people have money to spend on
your goods and services and if they
can't spend it with you they'll go and
spend it with somebody else
so what should you do with regard to
your own website
well you need to have two things
you need to have an audit of your
website and then you need to put an
accessibility statement on your website
I explain what I mean in this Photograph
this hotel it's a beautiful building
there's downstairs seating there's
upstairs ceasing there's beautiful
staircases everywhere but unfortunately
there isn't a lift
the restaurant itself is run by an
outside catering company it's not their
fault there's no lift it's not their
building they're just renting the space
however if you're in a wheelchair you
can't use the upstairs seating
but if there is a sign near the entrance
saying something like patrons in
wheelchairs please note that although
we've got upstairs seating
we do not have a lift however we do have
some reserve seating for you with extra
turning space and raised tables
thing about race tables if your opinion
will in a wheelchair and you try to go
into a restaurant anywhere you can't
quite get under the table easily fixed
just put them on some small wooden
blocks anyway if you just put up that
sign if somebody in a wheelchair who
reads that sign are they going to feel
more or less included
the cost of doing this is almost nothing
but the effect is huge it's not the
catering company's fault there's no lift
they've just gone out of their way to
offer an alternative
despite the limitations of the hotel
in other words the casing the catering
company themselves have become more
welcoming inclusive and accessible
so the first part of this story where I
explained the restaurant has upstairs
seating but no lift that could be seen
as an audit we've realized there's no
lift to the upstairs seating so disabled
people in wheelchairs cannot use it
but the sign of the entrance telling
everyone that there is accessible
seating downstairs as an alternative
it's like their accessibility statement
we've discovered that wheelchair users
can't use the upstairs seating this is
what we've done instead
so how does all this apply to your
website
well as far as the audit goes you can
either pay somebody or you can do it
yourself and the same goes for an
accessibility statement sadly I don't
have time to go into the details but I
do want to say one thing make your
accessibility statement real
what do I mean by this simple I I see
website after website with an
accessibility statement that begins with
a slightly pompous tone and it's just
something like we fully care about
people with disabilities we want to
ensure that everyone's able to fully
utilize our website it meets the
following standards blah blah blah I
don't actually really care what you say
somebody can't use your website they
can't use your website I've got an idea
why not instead use this as a wonderful
opportunity to reach out to disabled
people
first line of accessibility statement
could be something like we're aware that
there's some problems with our website
that might make the experience more
difficult
for visitors with disabilities but if
there's anything that we can do to help
you give us a call there's the phone
number right there follow this link to
send an email There's the link right
there or fill in the concept form right
there you're reaching out to them just
by doing that you're being inclusive
you're going the extra mile and it
speaks volumes about your ethos of a
company as a company
by the way if you do have accessibility
issues with your website you should give
a time frame in which you're going to
get them fixed or at least explain that
it's not possible grams of cost it isn't
about being perfect
it's about being honest
okay I'd like to finish by telling you
all about a very simple test that you
can do on any website to find out if it
has a basic level of accessibility
anyone can do it and I called it the tab
test
if you're on a website there will
usually be a row of page navigation
buttons along the top
As you move your mouse over them they
will light up in turn and any subpages
will appear as a kind of drop down and
they may also light up as you move the
mouse over in other words just by moving
your mouse you can go to pretty much any
page on the website with a single click
do we all understand that
brilliant
if you're blind as I've said you can't
use a mouse instead you use a screen
reader and a keyboard if a website has a
basic level of accessibility you should
be able to select every page and sub
page by repeatedly pressing the Tab Key
not only that each one should light up
and turn just as if you are using a
mouse
not everyone who is visually impaired is
completely blind in fact most of them
have some form of limited Vision instead
so having page navigation light up as
you move as You tab through them helps
them know where they are
so next time anybody here is on a
website just start pressing the tab key
if you do not see all the pages and all
the sub Pages light up in turn it's fail
to test
please drop them an inmate email
informing them that because their
website does not meet that basic level
of accessibility it's failed this test
and they really need to do something
about it they want to know more they can
do a quick internet search and actually
it's fairly easy to fix
if you guys joined with me in doing this
one simple thing
we all will truly be changing the world
warm episodes at a time thank you very
much